desde la dando pila en la costa
atlántica de francia una devastadora
perspectiva humo negro en el horizonte
los incendios arrasan los bosques del
suroeste del país este jueves los
bomberos evacuaron a los vecinos de las
áreas amenazadas
miles de personas han tenido que
abandonar la zona de media vuelta
no es que estemos muy nerviosas pero es
un fastidio para nosotros porque
estábamos hospedados allí y no tenemos
nada que ver evacuaciones puerta por
puerta frente a vecinos a veces
reticentes a abandonar sus hogares
señora hay que evacuar por el humo y
señor tiene que irse ya ya pero yo me
quedo aquí no puede ser tiene que irse
me da igual yo me quedo aquí ustedes
tampoco se quieren ir bueno así que
tiene una máscara de gas qué quiere que
le diga
en un contexto de fuertes y cada vez más
recurrentes olas de calor
11 departamentos franceses están en
alerta naranja el sureste la costa
mediterránea también arde los bomberos
intentan contener un incendio declarado
este jueves de momento no afecta a
ninguna residencia sin embargo las
autoridades temen que un cambio en el
viento este viernes reavive las llamas y
complique la extinción del fuego en la
que está siendo una temporada de
incendios
excepcionalmente precoz y devastadora